les séries ça fait un moment qu'ils
aient une musique que je kiffe aussi
c'est bien sûr
[Musique]
il ya deux chroniqueurs qui ont voulu
refaire cette chanson à leur sauce vois
franchement ils ont bossé comme des
chiens vraiment bravo à jean michel et
casta abat d'abord
benjamin castadi salut assez ouvert les
yeux ouvrir les yeux mais quand on voit
avec les yeux comme ça à 19 heures on se
demande comment ils sont le matin ça
rigolait le matin et soir 18 sur un an
dès demain matin je trouve ça laid que
j'ai une idée non j'ai envie de jouer
aux billes dans vos yeux
non mais arrêtez pénombre et si vous
savez comme ça je me dis comme ça et on
n'est pas comme cela on devrait lui
mettre des sacs bien celui là était
d'accord mais celui des mois vous ça va
comme on est au niveau de l'émission là
comme on est bien là le pauvre ça fait
de la peine c'est ça doit être dur de
faire ça on va essayer un jour quand
même arrêter ans est ce que j'aurais
fait pareil et maîtrise la lui mènera
ses amis à bord sans rigoler c'est
vraiment bien mais arrêtez je
souhaiterais bien que mes yeux que c'est
sûr que vous voyez bah oui je vois très
bien là c'est vrai alors vous allez voir
en tout cas vous avez fait un travail
exceptionnel
regardez ne sont pas au moulin qui aura
sera un tueur d'arc à regarder qu'à
méridien sex shop esprit champions
leaders ni patron ni faire plumer
huissier banques et ajouts pays
karsten des castors des gens me déjà
remis
j'suis gens me suivent royal
lui car je sais faute et je sais pas et
discret la voyante occasion les gars
trop aiguë pq il plus titulaire qui sa
manche aidant tmb ont fait 100 morts
côté libanais la boulette dégâts star
des gens dit je suis cafta décastar des
gens me suis un gars
je suis jean michel hayat
je suis carte à jouer
[Musique]
je suis en me jetant adra yahia
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui ils vont tirer pas un peu le tube de
l'été quoi ça sent qu'elle est mon bon
alors lovetch de l'été ccs l'enfant ils
seront peut-être derrière